could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i felt like i had been given everything
i've ever wanted and then someone had
gone but you can't have it i've never
felt so lonely in my life
[Music]
2015-16 it was really the first time
that i'd had fame i didn't know how to
cope with it so i just panicked all the
time i just want to sing
the day that i found out that the baby
had died i didn't have anyone to just
fall apart on and that's what i needed
that's what i wanted
when i sent you that voice note it was
around the time when you'd done a big
post about dave he was my guy
and i wish i could have protected him
from himself like he protected me for
myself
that's the bit that hurts me the most
between dave and jamal
the things that those people
gave me in my life are things that i
know i have to find in myself
you've got this bougie-ass place and
you've got kitchen wow i love it
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
i tend to believe that people's family
are their foundation
and when i was reading through the story
of your family in your early years
actually seemed pretty idyllic
yeah i mean
we weren't my mum and dad i didn't grow
up with loads of money like we weren't
hard hard but we weren't rich
um but when i think about it again like
the one thing that i've learned from my
parents the most
is it doesn't matter about the things
and the specifics it's about the energy
you create within what you have so like
we would go camping in the garden
and my dad would pretend to be a bear in
the middle of the night and we i believe
to this day it was a bear like you know
my mom's like looking out the window
because she's gone in because she's like
i ain't doing this and my dad yeah my
dad's peeing in a bucket yeah they're
still doing it like not in front of us
because that would be weird but like
just they used to just create
these
experiences
and it was all about feeling and
that's what i remember the most from my
childhood
like more so than
anything else like it's weird like i was
in hospital a lot of my childhood
and
i never ever thought i was sick
because my mom and dad never treated me
as if i was
like they would
it was it would never it never became a
definitive of who i was which is i think
even why now i don't
define myself on that i don't want to
even when other people try but
there was just always this
air of making the best of whatever the
moment was
even if it was tough
your dad worked in mental health yeah a
mental social worker how did that
influence your early years
well my dad is a pisces through and
through he's an emotional
honest hilarious very sensitive
um stubborn man and so growing up he's
very in touch with like his feelings and
his emotions which isn't common in a lot
of men you know
and
we grew up
talking
and i spent a lot of time with my dad
when i was young and
he used humor
in his job and with us as me and my two
sisters and his relationship with my mom
she made her laugh and even now my dad's
humor is his defense his his way of
hiding his way of making friends his way
of healing
and
him being a social worker was always
that beautiful thing where he used to
ride the line where he would open you up
know that you were going to cry and then
make you laugh
and you always feel safe when you're
very very sad
and then you laugh
the emotions always kind of
they intertwine like deep sadness and
like
intense happiness are so close together
that like feeling when you're at a
funeral and everyone's crying and then
someone makes a joke and everyone bursts
into laughter like that's the line that
my dad is incredible at
kind of balancing
you're good at that too because which is
where i get it from
some of your hardest moments in your
yeah i make a joke but i use it in a way
to
allow people to feel safe including
myself
to bring out the sadness and the pain
you know and to
to talk about something really really
intense
um or go through a moment that's hard
but then make make a joke or make
light of the situation or laugh at
ourselves you know and then like go into
bird's eye view and look down and go
look at our slot you paid 30 quid to
come and cry
you know what i mean and it's like and
it's that thing if you just come in tap
him back into reality and just going oh
god like it's not
i'm not alone like and it's it's good to
laugh and laughter can feel as
to me as connective as crying with
someone as being intimate with someone
there's that thing that you have where
if you're really in that moment it's
such a release
you said you spent a lot of your time as
a kid in hospital yeah what was the the
first
time you went to
hospital first memory i have i think i
was eight
and we was in epping forest if you end
up in forestry probably not well you can
go it's lovely
in the forest yeah so
yeah it always starts in a forest and
it's like an episode of black mirror so
me and my sisters my dad were in the
park
and he said right let's race to the car
so we started to run and i just remember
i couldn't breathe
and i collapsed and the next thing i
remember is my dad picking me up and run
into the car
we got into the car we went to the
hospital
and my dad has wpw my granddad had wpw
which is a heart problem and so i that
was the first time i was taken in with a
regular irregular heartbeat
i was put on very heavy medication as a
child
um which would cause me to have like
seizures and pass out
um and have
like it was just awful
um so i was in and out of hospital a lot
as a child it was weird like i remember
being let out for the day to go and do
rehearsals for bugsy malone
and then i would go back in so i'd be on
a drip at the rehearsal so there was
always this kind of balance that kept me
present in myself and not and i almost
think that that was that's been my
blessing in my life
like my health has always kept my feet
on the ground
um in many ways but
i never remember being in hospital and
being aware of what i was going through
every memory i have i'm always thinking
about the people i watched and remember
like
looking at going god they need a
magazine or they haven't eaten anything
today or
i wonder how they're feeling i don't
remember being in pain or
coming around from an operation or it's
weird it's trippy it's almost like
it didn't happen
you define yourself as an empath you
said it when you came yeah for sure
and even people that hurt me i feel bad
for the people that hurt me because i
look at why they've hurt me as opposed
to the way i feel
but again
i don't know i try and use it as the
best i can because i know it's just who
i am
when you're in hospital one of the
things that you saw was um which
inspired big white room yeah was a boy
laid next to you yeah so i was in a it
was a ladybird ward
and um
there was a little boy in the room with
me and i remember waking up in the
middle of the night and he was crying
and
praying and had like
all of these like tubes and you know
like
the bloodlines and stuff coming with
this what's it called i don't know what
it's called but like he just had all
these things and he was just going
please don't let me die i'm so scared
don't let me die god i want to i want to
stay here i really want to be here and
he was i can't i ca he was
probably
10 or 11
and
i woke up and i remember just sitting
and watching him
for hours
and just listening to him
and then the next morning i remember
seeing his mum come in and just taking
all the balloons
and i said to my mom like
i was upset and i just remember saying
why
you know why
why wasn't he
why isn't he here now like he asked
so nicely
and my mom just said you know sometimes
god needs his angels closer to him
and i remember that moment stayed with
me for years
you know i was probably 10 when that
happened
and when i was 16 17 i had to write a
song about it was the first song i wrote
and it stayed with me that was the way i
needed to let that
feeling out
you know of like
everybody's looking at me and everyone's
staring at me what do i do now i smile
because i'm still here
i don't want to be here and i don't
remember what i felt like before
you know and obviously since that moment
that experience and then when i wrote
the song i'd also gone through a lot
more
health stuff and experiences
um
but that was the most human thing i'd
ever seen even though i wasn't conscious
of the fact that it was
how long did that last that the health
issues in your sort of pre-18 years in
terms of going in and out of hospital uh
not very long i mean it was it was a
it was chunks of time and i had an
ablation which is like a little
operation they do where they put
two wires through your shoulder and two
wires through your groin and they try
and kind of electrocute your heart into
a normal rhythm
and it didn't work so i get a regular
heartbeat now but i just i don't take
any medication
i believe in good diet
and like how i feel and
i try and do everything the holistic
natural way
um
i don't believe in medicine as much as
other people do
but i think it was funny because i
actually got to a point where i felt a
lot stronger and i was in a stride and i
was i got you know i was in a girl band
and i was at the brit school and i was
like
i'd cut my hair and i was a veto sassoon
model and i was like you know i'm
starting to feel like i can fit in and
i'm not the sick kid that can sing
you know and then i had a stroke when i
was 17.
and then it kind of again kind of took a
dip and then i'd get back on my feet and
i'd get signed and then i broke my foot
you had a stroke at 17. you had a stroke
in hamley's you know it's the toy stop
yeah yeah yeah yeah i worked there doing
now jazz now art
um and i was like i don't feel very well
and i was like doing a lot
i've always been someone that's like
overexerted myself and probably doesn't
know when to take a break
and yeah i lost the feeling on the right
side of my body for almost a month
and now all my issues have been on this
side
like this side of my body so i know like
it's so weird cause like when people go
my god you had a stroke and i'm like
yeah i don't even think about it
i don't define i don't want to define
myself on it i don't want to introduce
myself with it
because like i'm grateful it happened
because
if those things hadn't happened in my
life
you know the many years the the uterus
issues i've had the fertility thing the
miscarriage like
you grow in moments of sadness and pain
you know and i grew up in those moments
and i didn't take my body for granted
and i think it's actually given me more
moments of beautiful
success and joy in my life not
drowning my body in alcohol and drugs
and
having to take moments of still and
resting and
it was almost like
a very young age a very pivotal time of
my career kind of starting to take off
and more of a this could actually be my
life why
my body was would always keep me safe
even though it was
shutting down
it would always just remind me to go
you're not superhuman you could die
don't [ __ ] this up
you know and so it almost feels like my
health has just always had my back
when
my life has gone
like this it's always kind of going to
take a second and for a long time
i felt like i was cast with this spell
that like every time i kind of got
somewhere like i was just about to break
america and i broke my foot and i had to
pull out of opening for katy perry on
tour and all these things that like
you know you've got your thing you sit
with your team and you go this is going
to happen in this and great and
everyone's excited and then i get sick
and
you know even to recently
i was about to release my album and
my first single and then i was in a car
accident and i had a throat issue where
i had nerve and tissue damage and i
couldn't sing and then my meniere's and
i went deaf in this ear and
but now i don't even want to release
that album because i don't really like
the music really and i'm like maybe
that's why it happened i just feel like
i've been protected by
my health being
what other people would see as bad but
every time something happens to my body
i'm always like okay
what am i not listening to
like so i feel like that's my personal
way of looking at it in my journey so
like when you say
you know how long was that for it's kind
of been my whole life
you know even up until
recently when
you know right when i got my voice back
and i started doing these shows and i
finally was told i could sing again and
i phoned my agent and i was like i have
to do like a
i don't know like a residency somewhere
and i started doing these acoustic shows
and i was like i really want to do stand
up you know i want to do comedy i want
to make people laugh and sing that's
literally my purpose right
and then the day before the first show i
have a miscarriage
and i still went and did it
you know not because the show must go on
but to me like
jessie j and jessica cornish like jessie
j's just a brand name they go hand in
hand they're the same person
you know the reason that my music exists
is because my life exists
you know i write about [ __ ] i go through
you know so i want to stand in the
middle of the pain even when it's
terrifying and you're being exposed but
even in that moment i was like
this
i know this happened for a reason
you know like
the day that i found out that my the
baby had died
this man and i you know i can't make
this stuff up and i always wish someone
would see these things happen but i was
on the street crying
uncontrollably i felt like i'd
my body had gone numb like i was just on
the street and i
i was standing there and i couldn't move
i literally just stood at this bush for
like two hours
and i was phoning everybody that i knew
to try and answer the phone and just
because i was by myself i was in santa
monica
and this man came up to me and said
i don't know what's going on in your
life in this second but i know that it's
happening so that you can talk about it
and help other people
and i remember just going that's the
story of my life
and the anger i felt where i was like
why can't this just be about me
like why why do i have to help someone
else
and then i realized that is what i've
been called on to do
like i know that what i do is so much
bigger than me
it's not about the song or the the
accolades or the awards or this
it's about the feeling that you can hand
over to someone that they can't find
themselves
and
i have experienced so many things that
are so randomly rare
and then also i've experienced things
that aren't rare at all but no one talks
about
and the amount of women and men that
have been close to someone losing a baby
or having infertility issues or
losing children themselves or even women
that have had children that don't know
how to connect with their children
talking about that pain
not only
helped me but helped other people and i
know that like going back to what you
asked me before like i know that's so
much of my purpose as much as hard as it
can be in moments
i get so much
peace from knowing that
pain that i know i can handle
and have a different perspective of
than someone else that might not
that i can share that with them and give
them a different perspective as they can
me but obviously i do it on a
maybe a bigger platform
it is such an amazing feeling for me
to be able to give that to someone that
can't find it on their own
it's a heavy weight to carry to always
have to be the inspiration though right
yeah for sure but it isn't always the
case
um but i think it's just understanding
that
like understanding that
after i did that first show
a huge part of me regretted it
because i was angry that i reacted as
jessie j i reacted as my brand i reacted
as
i need people to know i'm okay like i
don't want people to think i'm this
always sick
always
ill always have something going on like
didn't she just
go deaf that's the comments didn't she
just
like da da da da you know like when you
go into a new relationship people like
wasn't she just with so-and-so and it's
like that was two years ago but
they live in a little bubble of when
they want to discover things you're
talking about doing the show the the
show after the day after had a
miscarriage like in the sense of the
reaction of of going
i must the show must go on i must
i after that show i surrendered to my
pain
and for nobody else but myself and
that's something that i've i don't think
i've ever done
and a lot of grief came out
grief of of grandparents of friends of
people that i've lost that it all came
out in that moment and still is to be
honest it was only four months ago that
this happened five months ago
so
i feel like a lot of grief that i had
stored in
interviews where i was like you know and
you've just got to find this and it's
always looking for the silver lining i
actually just enabled myself
to just break open and
be miserable and sad and
not have a quote at the end of my
moment and just go no it's [ __ ]
and i'm broken and it's awful and i'm
sad
but knowing that the light would come
and it did and
it is
um
but knowing that speeding up my
process of grief
because it makes somebody else feel good
is great but also not going to be
healthy for me
do you remember the day when you found
out that you would struggle to well the
doctor told you that you would struggle
to have children oh yeah
it was in the middle of a really major
busy time for me it was right before
bang bang
and i was doing all these different
shows
and i basically would have this extreme
pain
like
agonizing pain i would pass out it was
awful and they were like you have ibs
and i was like no i don't
i know i don't have ibs
like
and they would just be like yes you do
that's what it is and i was like no i
know myself i know my body
i know it's not ibs
and i stuck with it and i was like i
went to keep kept going to see different
doctors and i finally got diagnosed with
endometriosis which is very common and
then
i had an operation
that you know they took all the
endometriosis my endometriosis out i
went home
i still live with my parents
i went home and i was still in agony
and i was still having the episodes
and so i went back into hospital
and they did another operation where
they discovered i have adenomyosis
which is a form of endometriosis that
goes into the wall of the uterus
so they're
little cells that you can't take out
unless you take your uterus out
so
they were like you either manage the
pain which at the time i was like how do
i do this
or
we take your uterus out right now and i
was what 26
and also and he was like i would
recommend you to do that
you know this is only going to get worse
and i said i'm good
i'll go home and i'll look at other ways
i can
look up and manage my pain and that's
when i went plant-based that was you
know years and years and years ago
and it definitely helped and improved
and
i changed my lifestyle and
kind of slowed my pace down
you know after that record the bang bang
sweet talker record and i took a long
time
not off but just slowed down
and that's
when i wrote the rose album and so
there's like behind the scenes there's
always a story for everybody um but yeah
that moment was super pivotal for me
a lot of things happened at once i was
reading that i think it was around the
time you're in australia yeah in 15 2016
time and you were you'd lost your
grandparents yeah within like four or
five months of each other you had a
breakup yeah
i broke up my first breakup that was
kind of public because i was someone
that was just you know was famous and
just discovering myself you know like it
was really the first time that i'd had
fame in america too
and so like when i was famous in the uk
like i obviously i came here a lot and
it was kind of great because i was like
i could just do whatever i want and no
one cares so it was kind of like i could
just
escape to just live
completely in the knowledge that i would
leave my house or my hotel
and for the whole day no one would be
like
you know like or just come up to me with
a camera phone or whatever and i just i
needed that i was still quite young and
you know and i i miss staring at people
and
getting away with it
you know what i mean just like watching
people eat or like
staring at someone in the car next to
you and knowing they're not going to
look over and be like
you know and so
i remember coming here and just having
that and then i didn't have that as much
anymore here
and i just
felt really trapped
really trapped
like
that was the lowest point that i've had
in myself
in this industry was
2014
15 16
in when i was back and forth from
australia and
in that time that's when i moved here
in 2015.
when you say trapped what's the symptoms
of being trapped what is that what does
that manifest i just felt like i
couldn't breathe
i felt like everywhere i went someone
was watching me
i felt like i couldn't eat in public
because someone would film me
and comment on it comment on what i was
wearing comment on my body comment on
i just it felt it always felt like i was
being followed that was the biggest
thing where my anxiety came from
and
someone
telling me
or giving me something that i would then
have to focus on that i never saw like
that i have a big jaw that i have like
this or i have cellulite or i have that
like where i would never even it wasn't
a thing and then someone would go have
you ever noticed that she like says like
um or like like like like a lot and then
i'd be like conscious of the way i spoke
and
you know like as when you first get
somebody commentating on everything you
do in r
i was just like
how do i
how do i live unconsciously now
like
how do i
go to the beach
without feeling like
i'm in my underwear in front of someone
hiding in the bushes taking pictures
how do i do that
you know and i still don't know
sometimes even now
and so i just
i felt like i couldn't
it felt like i had to re-learn how to do
life
like i i was comfortable going in front
of a hundred thousand people and singing
a song no problem
but going to perpetual in my car
i literally was i don't even know how to
do it i would drop the thing
like i i like wouldn't be able to lock
the thing on the car because i would
feel like someone was watching me and
like i it just destroyed me and i
remember just i wouldn't leave my hotel
room
like
i went out and bought like 50 hats
and even though it probably wasn't as
bad
as that
no you don't go to how like and i get
that even me talking about it now like
i'm conscious that the people watching
this going all right well you [ __ ]
ask to be famous get over it
like there's no space to feel like you
know what there's parts of it that are
amazing
but there are parts of it that are so
toxic and unhealthy and so inhumane
and no one
has a lot of space to be
um like to have any empathy for that and
that and i'm not talking about all the
time and just about that moment in my
life i just felt like i had no one i
could talk to
that had experienced it to guide me
to go
you're okay you're safe like
no one's gonna hurt you
you know and
i just felt so alone i felt like i was
hovering above everybody in every room i
was in like i wasn't able to just exist
playing a game at a friend's house that
i was always just like is everyone
thinking about what i'm saying and
they're going to repeat it and
so i just
panicked all the time
of that someone was going to misread
what i was saying or
if i was in a bad mood and i went to
like a
fish and chip shop and i was like we
didn't want to take a picture
that they would then tell someone else
and it would get to the daily mail did
that happen oh all the time
jessie j demar i mean there were times
where
i then would almost i remember i
remember for a little while for a couple
months i became what the press told me i
was
because i got so tired of justifying
that i wasn't mean
and i wasn't a diva
that was like here let me just be what
they say i am
because that's what people think i am
anyway and even when i am nice
like someone i remember going into a
room and being like hi everyone and no
one responding and me going
hi
and everyone's like this like
you know like when you're like at that
it's weird it's like a and that was like
and i'm talking about that time and it
was like peak
kind of everywhere fame saturday night
saturday night tv and
it was just such a trippy experience and
me just was like everyone hates me no
one likes me anymore
so i'm not going to try and be liked it
didn't last very long
if you could go back and speak to jessie
that was going through that that wasn't
staying in those hotel rooms and that
was yeah stumbling to put the petrol in
our car and
reacting to the media what would you
what advice would you give her
bird's eye view babes
just
imagine the best piece of advice i was
given from a therapist
was perspective
like
imagine the world go above it imagine
yourself flying above it and really look
at what you're stressed about
like get outside get some air
just get outside go to a park like take
a walk
you know and and also
be honest to your friends and your
family about how you're feeling and
allow them to be there for you because i
think everyone was kind of
everybody was kind of
swelled up in
i mean you've experienced it yourself
recently going from
being able to do whatever you do and no
one knowing who you are
to then everyone knowing who you are and
then everyone around you doesn't
instantly go are you okay they go this
is great
isn't it amazing
are you having so much fun and you don't
feel like you can go actually no
some of it's great but some of it's
really weird
and i need you to hold my hand
and i'm a little scared
and now i don't know how to get on the
train
when i never used to think about that
and now i have to rethink about it and i
go can i go on this central line on a
saturday at peak time
no
so how do i get to where i need to go
because my status is way higher than my
money
and i can't afford a driver
you know and your and your mind is going
who do i talk to about this
where do i and that's when i was 25 26
and i shaved my head and i did all of
that i was just like
what is happening
and who do i tell that will understand
you know
so yeah
did you find anyone that understood um
yeah i think
i had to learn that
talking to my loved ones
i remember sending out a message to
everybody going saying unless i am
in danger
or you don't think i've seen something
that's really bad that's been put in the
papers i don't want to see it amen oh
that's the worst i don't want to see it
i don't want don't send me a link of me
on the beach because i was there
my friends and my family sending me
links of people criticizing me have you
seen this
[ __ ] i'm like yeah i said to my mom and
dad and my brothers and sisters super
early doors yeah don't just do that in
the comments section on this website
tell me don't send me the link i'm not
bothered i'm not looking if you want
also the thing that they need to be
focused on and this is what i had to say
to my friends and family
stop focusing on
what the other people are saying
focus on helping me be someone that can
be within that
like
it doesn't matter what [ __ ]
donald from manchester thinks about my
outfit that i wore
what matters is
that i still feel confident
wearing those things after i've i may or
may not have been forced to read those
comments
because that's the other thing like fan
bases will sometimes shove that in your
face going can you believe this and it's
like i don't want to see it
i don't want to read it and sometimes
you're like they you literally can't
avoid it
so your closest friends and family that
was the biggest thing for me was making
them understand like
i need you to be there for jess who's in
the dressing room
not worrying about what the people think
that are in the audience watching jessie
j
i need you to care about the girl
backstage
before i even step on the stage
when you're a performer and you're in
the public eye yeah you see it you've
got to create basically a brand as you
call it yeah you make the distinction
between jessica and jesse and whatever
and they're really the same person but
yeah man same person is there a point in
your life where you
your identity got too caught up in being
jessie j yeah for sure when i wouldn't
know what to wear like i'd wear a cat
suit and like
my bob wig to like
like a family barbecue because i just
didn't know how to like tone it down i
was just on this hamster wheel of like
dude
like
and i just didn't know how to like i
didn't know who i was away from working
you know so like
one thing i realize now is that you are
a product of your environment
you are a product of your environment
and i see that in my my niece and my
nephews you know like and all the young
people i know and i watch my best
friends and my close family members have
children and i see how different their
kids are because they they are a
reflection of their environment you know
and the beauty that they can have if
they're
brought up in the middle of nowhere in
the countryside but then they're like
not streetwise and they kind of
you know and all these things and so
like when i look at like how i was
in those pivotal moments of my life
and i think this is why i have so much
empathy for young art like younger
artists and like i really care about
how they're protected
um
and just young people in general
like
protected from what the world is telling
them they are as opposed to them
discovering themselves
like i was a product of when i wake up
i'm working like this is what you wear
this is what you do this is how you act
this is what you say
and so like i didn't know how to switch
off like i would literally have to leave
the house on a full face of makeup and
like without
it was weird it was like a trippy i
remember going on holiday with a couple
of my girlfriends
and we were going for dinner and like
i was so stressed about what to wear and
how to do them and it was so dumb it's
not even like important but it was
moments like that when i was just like
god i need to chill out i'm not jesse j
right now but i didn't know who i was
i literally had no clue like what my
favorite color was or what food do i
like to eat because i would just get
given this is what we've got
this is what you've got time to eat for
so long it was so
unhealthy fast it was just everything
was so speeded up
and i was like what do i want to what
are my hobbies
what do i like to do other than just
sing and travel
i can travel to sing
i don't know
and that's when i was like okay i need
to take a second and after that third
album i took like four years
and disappeared
in that time you've got record labels
telling you presumably who you are who
they want you to be not even you know
what it's one thing i will say about my
record label
you know for as much as
we you know you always have your your
your disagreements with anybody in power
and anybody you know that's
you work for or work with or work under
or work next to like but my record label
have always supported me
um
to the best of their ability and and to
the best that i understand like the rose
album the last album i put out was my
favorite that i've ever put out was it
the most successful no was it the most
authentic to who i was at the time yes
did it have the biggest support for my
label no
did that matter to me at the time no
because i knew that the music was great
yeah would have been great
had they been
more supportive but
it didn't
again it didn't def it didn't take away
from the purpose of what that moment was
for me personally
so no they've been great they've been
amazing and even now they're super
supportive that like
first time i'm talking about it that i
had an album that was done
ready to go
and i listened to it a couple months ago
and was like this ain't it
and then i went back in the studio three
days ago to kind of start again
and maybe i'll use some of the old songs
maybe i won't maybe i'll rework them
but there just was something that wasn't
right and they're like we support you we
love you we got you
we see you we understand you i've been
with them for almost 15 years
what i've struggled to find is an
internal team
like people that are immediately around
me
like an assistant a manager that kind of
manager yeah managers assistant no
they're just a team
that's where i'm at right now like
you know i just let go of my sixth
manager two days ago
yeah
no hard feelings
no
great great people amazing at what they
do just not right for me
and i know it's because there's
something i'm doing wrong because i keep
picking the wrong people
so i know i need to look inwards and go
what am i doing wrong here is it because
i know i know what i want and i don't
really say it because i don't like to
cause waves in the ocean
kind of like a smooth sailing moment but
i also
know what i want i know what i deserve
and it's taken me a long time to be
confident in saying like i know i can
really sing
but i've just never had a team that
really get it
that like had the same passion as me and
like
live for like
the moments and like taking risks and
not being afraid and like
to like
you know and i'm i guess maybe i'm
talking about it right now because
if someone that's meant to be for me in
my life might see this because
you know like i say all the time like
people go what are you going to do now
like if you've got a new manager lined
up and i'm like
no
i didn't let them go because i've
secretly been meeting people like that's
not who i am
like one thing for sure is i'm loyal and
like i'm respectful but like when you're
your manager is like a it's almost like
a marriage you know you go into a
contract and you hand over a very big
important part of your life
you can't look for a new husband while
you're still married it doesn't work
like that
and i have no idea who good managers are
no idea
and i don't know if i ever will
i'm 34 i've been doing this a long time
but i also know that i've got so much
more to do
and i feel like i've barely scratched
the surface
and i know in my heart in my instinct
i don't just trust my instinct i act on
it
and it was a big brave thing for me to
do just to go guys i love you but i know
this ain't right i'm moving on
what wasn't right about it outside of
the passion you're looking for what is
what is it you're looking for from that
team that manager it's so funny because
when someone goes what do you what are
you looking for in a manager
for me it's just a feeling i just
thought like it's someone that
i'm such a hard worker right
and i'm very disciplined
i'm very professional
i can hand a lot of stuff by myself
and i think that exposes a lot of people
to do one of two things go she's good
or i need to work harder
and a lot of people go she's good
and i just want someone that
can teach me
about music can send me
performances from aretha that i've not
seen or
hey have you heard this new music or
have you read this book or
like you know what i was thinking be
amazing if we did this like okay so you
want to do this i need
the drive the passion like people that i
can relate to
like the way they
see the world and
feel the world and like
like i get told and i'm so grateful
i get told all the time you're one of
the best singers in the world
there's some singers down the street at
church that are the best singers in the
world
that no one will ever hear other than
than god and the people that are in the
church
but that doesn't mean anything
like if you're not doing anything with
it
you know and i and and
i just want a team of people that
represent me even when i'm not in the
room you know have you seen what you're
looking for elsewhere
i don't even know i don't even i don't
know
i know i look at other artists and go i
should be doing that there's no reason
that i shouldn't be there i shouldn't be
doing this or
i know that the music that i make
like i've always said this metaphor with
my career right
is i feel like
if my career was a shop i feel like i
sell ladders outside
but rose is on the inside
so i feel like
what i put out there isn't always what i
actually
sell
that isn't actually always me
that i feel like i'm
convinced or
i'm i'm i'm always a little afraid to be
a diva to come across like i'm arrogant
or this that and the other but like i
know the best moments of my career point
blank have been when i have followed
my
instincts acted on my own
heart like when i did the china tv show
everyone was like why is she doing why
why do you want to do a singing
competition i said just i just know this
is what i need to do you know even the
rose album
like i know that the people that
discovered that
were who needed to discover it and i
just know like
the only thing in life that is important
is to just not trust your instincts but
to act on them
be yourself and not be afraid
to know that even if you're in a room
full of people that if you know that
this is gonna work
just don't
be disheartened by everyone else's
projection of their own fear that they
can't deliver for you
i guess you'd also rather fail at being
yourself than succeed at being someone
else as well right and i've succeeded at
being someone else one honey p
that's one hundred percent yeah that's
good
one honey yeah just professional
you're like um
but like i love to write songs right and
i can sing so i go in the studio and i
can make music but sometimes i'm like i
love this i love these songs but
i wouldn't buy this album
i wouldn't i wouldn't put this on and
listen to it
and i'm grateful that i know i've been
accepted into so many different
spaces in the industry like the musical
theater world and like the pop world the
r b world the soul like i'm so i love
music and i grew up around a lot of
music and i grew around a lot up a lot
around different cultures and races and
walks of life and i'm so
so happy that that was my foundation and
that's what i am and i also need
management to represent that
i don't want to walk into rooms that
everyone looks the same
you know i'm tired of it
and
i wanna
make music that makes everybody feel
like that they're welcome and make music
that makes everyone feel accepted and
seen and understood and
i need my team to reflect that and i got
to do a better job
at making those decisions
one of the reasons i ask is if you've
seen it somewhere else
because it's because when you're a
obsessed person you're obsessed about
your craft
um i think we all and i'm speaking from
my own experience here we all struggle
when we don't feel like other people are
meeting us there
oh yeah you know what i mean and i see
this with founders specifically in
companies where they're they're just
absolutely obsessed and all in on their
dream and then they look at their team
who aren't at that standard don't seem
to care as much aren't you on sending
the aretha tracks at two a.m in the
morning yeah aren't going above and
beyond and they're thinking well you you
must not be right you must not care you
must not want to be here
um so there's a certain expectation no
for sure 100
and it's not that i'm saying i'm i
expect them to be me
i think it's just
people that even want to talk about
music yeah yeah you know like a lot of
managers like
when was the last time i went to see a
show like at the end of the day to me
that when you're a musician and you're
in the industry
i need a team of managers that are like
in
they're at the party they're not
trying to get me an invite they have to
be there and like coming you know what i
mean it's like
so i just i think that
i don't know what it is and i don't have
the answers and i don't know
i know what it is that i want
sometimes i don't know how to
to say that until i'm experiencing
experiencing that it's not what i want
and then i'm like no
like
this isn't right but i know that
it is also me
and i know that i have to be more vocal
on what it is that i want and what it is
that i deserve
and i just feel like i'm always taken
for granted and i just
i just
i just want to sing and like
really
be in the mix and work hard like the
fire in my belly now is like
what do you mean by being relaxed
it's weird when you've had success
like
people always say to me like yeah but
you're jessie j and i'm like what the
[ __ ] does that mean
i haven't even been invited to the brit
since 2011.
so what does it mean
i'm jesse j like
what is my success to you because it's
different to me obviously
you know and i think people go
and a lot of the time especially other
artists
they see that maybe you've had success
in places that they haven't or that
you've got something that they have and
they go yeah but why aren't you just
content with that
you know and everyone's everybody's
different with what they need to feel
successful
does comparison ever get the best of you
in your industry
no
you've never looked at another artist
and gone maybe i should be doing more or
no i look at other eyes and go man i
wish i was more confident
i wish i was more like i see people work
in a room and i'm so shy that i come
across rude when i'm in a room a lot
with a lot of people
i instantly go into that no one likes me
no one's going to get my sense of humor
like i have so
so many insecurities that
i don't think i've even been consciously
aware of until like the last year
since covered and like taking a break
and then coming back to it and i'm like
oh my god like
i don't think anyone in this room knows
who i am and i don't know why i'm here
and i'm so awkward and i hate this and
what the hell am i doing and i hate this
gown i'm in
what am i doing here like i have those
moments all the time
and
the perception
and reality is such a weird like
experience to have of what you think
people think of you and then what they
do think of you and
it's
i don't look at other eyes and go god i
wish i was doing that i go
i wish i was more
sociable or more confident at
work in a room or
talking to people
because i know that what i have is
because i have it and what they have is
because what they you know like i don't
ever want to be anyone else i don't want
anyone else to ever be me
but
no comparison isn't the issue for me
it's it's
frustration that i know i'm capable of
doing the things that someone else might
be doing in my own way
but i don't know how to invite myself
into the room
and i'm like and they're like oh my god
like you want to come in
come in
but it isn't always me going hi can i
come in
because i don't know how to do that
without feeling like an absolute
[ __ ]
so i just kind of go
and hope that someone might go maybe
jessie j wants to come in
and you want a manager that's going to
say jessie j needs to be in there or to
go or to go
go on
you can do it stop don't get in your
head
i think that i can give off that i am
i'm grateful that
i can sing
and i'm grateful that i'm
love to sing live like i love that i've
never mind and i just that's not who i
am i love that like i
even if my voice is horse or whatever i
always put myself like in the exposure
like firing line right
what i love and hate about myself is
that
i can be put through the most ridiculous
experience like throughout the day i
could literally be set on fire and i
could probably still sing
and i hate that because it means that
people go
she'll be fine whatever the situation
and i think that's a big part of it is
that i've been i've trained myself to
be good in situations where i haven't
had people i haven't haven't had to let
people think that they need to level up
for me to deliver
like that's what has to change
because what's going on in here and
what's coming out and what people are
seeing can be two very different things
and i'm not connecting those dots
for anybody really but myself
because it's only going to make me have
a more of an enjoyable experience
those four years that you referenced
that you
i don't know how to discredit
disappeared
what was going on when you disappeared
oh my god what was going on i did the
voice
because i wanted to kind of
stay in the in the vibe
i did the china show
yeah the china tv show which was one of
my favorite things i've ever done
billions watching 1.2 billion people
watch the final and i bit my tongue
before i went out and sang whitney
because i was so stressed and i was just
blood in my mouth
um um trust me i'm very close to i have
[ __ ] myself on stage before that's what
i'm saying i'm so bad
so bad
it's so bad
fingers in the news
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you your 20 grams of
protein
if you haven't tried the heal protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like the salted caramel is my
favorite i've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is
the one is there a pressure in that four
years where people are saying why isn't
she giving us an album oh yeah it's
always pressure
yeah
and i it took me a long time to realize
that
i
can't you can't
squeeze from the lemons you gotta
nurture the roots a little bit you know
what i mean you can't just keep asking
the lemons to grow and there's no it's
not been potted in the ground
and i just needed to be regrounded i
just was like i wrote the whole first
album second album i wrote
pretty much the whole thing by a couple
songs the third album i wrote two songs
and when you listen to it i wrote two
acoustic songs get away and you don't
really know me
and everything else was burning up bang
bang didn't write any of them loved them
but it wasn't where i was
and i was exhausted and i was like just
i'll sing whatever you want and i was so
grateful for the success of masterpiece
burning up bang bang
in the us
but it was nowhere near where i was
mentally and trying to match those two
things was my
probably my most important thing that i
could have done so when that album ended
and then obviously i went for the first
my first kind of big
just my first big breakup it wasn't even
that it was public it was just like my
first big breakup that people knew about
um
lost both my grandparents i remember
when i i lost my grandad i had to
perform in central park right after
and i was really close to my granddad he
was a professional jazz drummer i
traveled the world we had the same heart
problem
just you know just very much he
understood the industry and would always
kind of give me advice
and just not being able to grieve and
like all of those things and was just
going to go and i need to take a second
to like process my life like i haven't
stopped since everything took off
um
and then
i went for a moment where i was like i'm
done with music i'm out really oh yeah
sat with my labels like drop me don't
want to do this anymore
i can't do it i'm emotionally exhausted
didn't know how to just i just didn't
know how to
write songs anymore i was just like what
do i even want to sing about when was
this 2016.
so after you lost your grandparents and
yeah
2016. and then i'm and then i had to do
this campaign cause i needed money
honestly like i was like i need to still
make money to be famous
like you gotta still be protected and i
have to like wean myself off of this
lifestyle if i'm gonna not do this
anymore
and i got offered to do a campaign with
makeup forever which i've always wanted
to do anyway because i i love the brand
and i said and i said i'd love to do it
and they're like we won an original song
and i was like i don't want to do an
original song cause if i do an original
song
people think i'm bringing an album and
it's a single and marilyn i was like
i'll do a cover
so i met this guy called camper
and he was in the studio and he was like
yo man like i got some tracks and i was
like no tracks
don't play me anything i don't wanna i
don't wanna do this no more he's like
come on let me just play you something
and i was like no no i'm good seriously
please don't i was like auntie i just
need to do this get the check go home
don't make me emotional don't you know
it's there
don't pull out that part of me like i
don't want to i was trying to pretend
that i was something different to who i
was and he played me this beat and he
was like i'm gonna go smoke i'll be back
in five minutes
and i was literally i was just sitting
there and he played me this this track
and i was like
sitting there and the engineer was just
like i'm in the behind the engineer and
i just start typing
on my laptop
and the engineer's like
you need to turn this off or and i was
like no no it's all right keep it on
and can i just jump in the booth real
quick
and i wrote this song called think about
that which became the first single of
the rose album
and i remember camper coming in going i
don't know who you think you are but you
can't stop writing songs
like this is what you do
and i think i'd realized that
really up until that point
a lot of my successful music had been
this kind of like everything's great
doesn't mean anything and i was like
that's what people want and i don't know
how to
deliver that
all the time when i can deliver it and i
do write songs like that now because i'm
not ignoring the pain
so i'm writing about both so they get
both as opposed to me ignoring all the
good like ignoring all the bad stuff so
that manifests into everything and then
that's all i want to write about
you know
and so i just started to write the
narratic queen and then i wrote
someone's lady on the spot and then i
wrote this and i wrote that and i kind
of had this album i was like
what do i do now
uh okay
you know and
when i went on that tour i fired my
managers during that tour
just firing managers left right and
center that's just been come a hobby of
mine
um can you imagine how insecure the
seventh manager's gonna be
or they're not you know the thing is i'm
such a loyal person if you look at
everyone in my life my production my
tour manager my hair and makeup ten
years deep
like i love my people
but i also need you to show me that you
really understand how valuable i am as i
would to you
you know like i can't
i know what it's like dating managers is
like dating
you know and i do believe that like such
an important role doesn't always just
fall into your lap and it's right
and i honestly think that most artists
will admit that they ain't happy with
the management
most people in the industry would admit
that they're not happy with their agent
or their management there's always
something else they could be doing and
like when you've voiced what you needed
and it still doesn't change and then you
voice it again and it still doesn't
change and then you go yeah
you know well i actually think i'd enjoy
this more if i didn't have
this
especially when you're making money off
not doing much
you know i'd rather
be by myself for a second and it'd be a
bit chaotic and me learn and like go
right what do i need what do i want what
do i need what do i want that's one of
the uh two of the questions that i think
a lot of people manage to get clarity on
during
terms of part yeah moments of turmoil
the pandemic yeah
exactly what was that to you that whole
two years
the pandemic was uh
probably the worst and most beautiful
thing that i think's happened to the
world
because when else would we all have to
stop
and not just stop and be like oh i'm
gonna keep going to work and like you
know just really take the weekend off
like stop
like
not have our clutches of our hobbies
not have our clutches of our friends and
family that we may see or visit or talk
to
but really
go inwards and have no escape from it
if i was a fly on the wall in your
wherever you were living during the
pandemic what would i have observed i
mellowed a lot in the in the pandemic i
let go of a lot of things that i held on
to as like
clutches to kind of be able to do my job
like i'm a very organized person
and
i realized how much time i wasted on
things that really didn't help
me
like having certain amount of
this or
being overly prepared i'm a very overly
prepared person
i cooked a lot
and i wrote an album
that's really good
but i just don't know if i really love
it why
i don't know who the audience is
when i listen to the songs i don't see
the people that are listening to it with
me
and
i have to be able to see that how did
that happen
if you write something i'm guessing
usually you write it from a place of
your own pain or whatever yeah so
there's gonna be people out there
feeling the same human experience
music reflects where you're at right
well it should
and
in that time i think
it was a very anxious at all everyone
kind of wanted to like falsify this like
we're good right
we're okay like we're okay we're good
we're gonna be fine and like you can
feel that in the music
it just feels a bit like too much
and i think that
what i think people are craving more
than ever right now is just like
real
like and i also know what i'm good at
and i listen to it and go there's like
about five or six artists that i can
imagine doing this
i want to make music people only know
that i can do
and it ain't that
so
and it might be that i might come full
circle and go you know what i was wrong
huh joke
took three years but we're here
but i'll get there you know there's no
right or wrong answers i don't believe
that anything we do in life is wrong or
right i just think we've got one and
make a decision and then we'll learn
from either which way we went has your
grief over the last year impacted your
perspective on that piece of work
yes
yeah
i feel like my grief is here
right now
like it just comes up and it comes out
my eyes or it comes out my my in my
songs
but it it it feels like it's
um
has a place to
has a place to live in my life now
which is why i probably feel so
vulnerable at the moment because
as i said to you like
losing
having a miscarriage and losing the baby
and then
most recently losing jamal edwards
when you don't just have one person
that you associate with grief but you
have a handful of people that
you realize that no one else
that you have in your life give you that
gives you what they gave you
and you realize that you have to find
that for yourself
like that's the
the hardest
part of grief for me that i'm
experiencing right now
um
like i don't even it's
like
even me crying like this like i can't
stop it like they're not tears where i'm
like you know when you can't not cry
like i'm not even trying to cry it's
just like it's here and it just comes up
um
it puts everything in perspective that
all the things that we worry about
and all the things that we are concerned
about
nothing matters if someone just loses
the like
when you watch someone
i don't know if you knew jamal
you did his parents called me yesterday
oh i love brenda
um
he was um i'd spoken to him
um a few months uh a few weeks before he
had passed yeah
yeah yeah he was when i was 18 and i've
this has been to the top of my twitter
he was my my
the evidence that i could make he's
successful yeah so i would stalk him
around skype when he was on skype and
i'd try and get him to speak to me yeah
it's it's crazy how much
time he made for everyone i can't
he was like so special like
you know and when someone passes you
always want to remind everybody of like
the good that they were but he was
like in another league of
i can't explain it like when
i was standing
you know
at his funeral and just looking around
and the impact that he made
so one-on-one with everyone he knew
because he never said no
he always had the time
and
i know how much he wanted to live life
you know and how
unfair it feels that
of all people
that that could have happened to that it
happened to him
i know that his passing has enabled
me to make the decisions that i'm making
in my life right now and my career with
more
strength and belief in myself like
jamal was someone that i spoke to when
i didn't want to do this anymore
when i didn't feel like
you know
being told that you're a great singer
was enough like it often wasn't you know
and i would phone him and he would just
remind me of i mean i met when i was 17.
just remind me of
the bigger picture and
just his energy and
the fact that he talked himself into
every room
and then talked about everyone else
you know i just
you felt his you felt his power when the
world found out he had gone
everybody was sad even people that
didn't know him
because
his
legacy that's been a word that's been
used a lot with him
it's funny because
the biggest legacy that i think he
however many
businesses he started and things he
invested in and
platforms he created to to elevate
everyone else
it was the feeling that he gave people
to me that was his legacy
and like
that's why i missed the most
and i when i i sang at his um homecoming
and everyone's like how did you do that
i said because i was singing to him i
was singing for him it wasn't a
performance
you know i know that
he would have loved that
i gotta just hit i just hear him going
geez you know like come on
are you wearing vegan shoes and that
um
but i think that the biggest thing that
you learn when you lose someone so young
that you love and admire so much
is that life is too short
to sit
anywhere other than where you're
supposed to be
and if you're sitting at a table where
you don't feel like you're being fed
even if you're bringing a plate of food
you politely just leave
you know and i and i know that he has
inspired me to
demand more from myself and from other
people
um
in my career you know me and him
had so many plans of projects that we
were doing together as i'm sure you guys
were probably supposed to connect in
some way
and i know that wherever i
was supposed to receive from him
for those things i have to find within
myself
so because no one will ever be that
so
sorry i'm so crying right now like i'm
such an emotional person and i really
live from feeling
and i'm not afraid anymore to be
vulnerable and i think that the first
first line of change with anything
through grief or anything like that
is talking about how you feel
and i think that i'm now in the next few
months aware that i'm gonna then start
actioning
the change that i'm speaking about
within myself
the energy around me what i want my
career to look like what i want my music
to feel like
what i want the people to be around me
to feel like
you know i love to work hard but i also
like people around me to have a life
i was when you you know when i was
re-reading through the the process you
went through with um
with your miscarriage yeah
you
posted about it very soon after and you
talked about it yeah and then you
deleted the post right or you archived
it or something
in a moment of being human i was just
like
you know what it was it was a moment
where i actually had it up
and i wasn't in a space to keep posting
but i was tired of going back to my page
and that being the thing that people saw
because i wasn't in that space but i
wasn't in a
hi guys i'm going to sing you a song
space or a
like
a random caption and a picture of me
just in and out you know so i just was
like i'm not as sad as that but i'm not
anywhere near say the view post before
it yet so let me just archive it and
just kind of go back to zero
i just can't imagine as a you know i've
had people who've sat here and talked to
me about miscarriages and the experience
especially the the attempt in a family
to try and create life and struggling
and yeah you know so seeing that so
closely and the experience you shared
and the way you shared it and even
listening to you talk about
going and having you know you had a
suspicion that someone yeah yeah
yeah and i had two scans in the same day
and
within the first scan and the second
scan the baby had passed and it was it
was such a
i mean the whole experience was so
spiritual for me because obviously i'd
been told it wasn't going to be easy for
me to get
um
to have children and realistically like
i still discovering that now i think
that any woman can can say that
the amount of women that are told that
and then they have children you know and
a lot of its mentors you know and where
our bodies are at and obviously when i
was going through all that pain and
discomfort was when my life was in
complete utter
chaos with my career and my diet and
everything you know like your mind your
body's so powerful and
as i've gotten older and in my life as
i've kind of tranquil like now to find
tranquility in the chaos and you know
like
just my pain is so much better and i'm
not on any medication anymore and
you know so when i fell pregnant it
wasn't
i know that i know that getting pregnant
i don't think would be the issue for me
it would be staying pregnant
and so when i fell pregnant
i was so
overwhelmed with like
your whole life just kind of
instantly changes you feel like you're
carrying the most precious cargo even
though it's the size of like a bean
sprout you're literally just like
and it's a secret but it's you and i'm
such an open person
and it was such a new experience for me
to
go through something
that so many people could relate to
but not want to tell anyone
but want to tell everybody but no i
shouldn't just in case but then it's
like but it's also something that so
many people have gone through so it
wasn't like a per you know and i was
just like what do i do and then when i
bought these shows
obviously i'd book them i think i'd put
them before i even knew
and then
when i decided to do that first show i
remember the day before i found out that
baby had passed i was with a friend of
mine and i was like how am i going to do
the show
and not tell everybody tell everyone
you're pregnant yeah and announce it
yeah and just say like
because i was like
so sick
you know i was like people are gonna
know
you know it's uh so i just i just
remember kind of landing in l.a and i
was by myself you know i live in l.a by
myself
and
i have friends and i don't have any
family here but like i have my team
um well i did have my team
so sad until i fired everybody no it
sounds so savage it's not it's so
amicable and everything's fine
um
but no i mean i do have a lot of team
you know a lot of them are in the uk
still and i do have people here and my
but like i have friends here and and i
remember i got here and i was very sick
and i was just like i'm going to start
working out and eating good and like
getting on a routine and like i have my
house and i'm in the sun and and then i
woke up one morning i was like oh i
don't feel right i still had very
intense nausea i just knew
something
something wasn't the same
and
i called uh a doctor because i hadn't
actually discovered who i was going to
have as my doctor yet because it was
still quite early and i'd gone to see my
doctor in london because i was there
when i found out
and i and i went to the doctors and
that dreadful silence when you first
have a scan and they kind of don't say
anything and i was like just tell me the
truth what's going on and she said
your baby's heartbeat is very low
um
and there's this like ring
and
and i was like what does that mean and
she said it often means that the baby
will have some sort of disability or
deformity and i said okay and she said
you know we can have you and take blood
in a couple today and then in a couple
of days and just to see if your your
hormone levels are moving to see if the
baby's still growing
but the baby's heartbeat is very weak
and i was like but it's still there and
she's like yeah it's still there
and that's when i went onto the street
and i cried and the man came up to me
and said you know if this is happening
because
you're supposed to talk about this
you're supposed to help other people and
instead of going to get bloods
i got in my car and i said i'm gonna go
and get a second opinion
i didn't go and get the bloods ever
and i phoned around
some friends and no one was available
and everyone's at work and
i ended up
being able to go and see another doctor
very quickly and he only had about 10
minutes before he had to go into a
surgery
and so i went in very quickly and he did
another scan and he said i'm really
sorry there's no heartbeat like
it's that was about within about three
four hours of the first one
and
i remember
going into the car park and getting in
the car
and one of the first people i spoke to
was someone on my team
you know and obviously you know they
were supportive and understanding but
one of the first things i was asked was
what do you want to do about the show
tomorrow
and even though i understood
i understood it you know i didn't at the
time i don't think i realized that that
actually really shifted the way i
processed the experience
you know i got home and i kind of was
focused on how am i going to get through
tomorrow's show
more than
what is happening
like i'm now so if you can hear my
stomach i'm really hungry um it's like
i need this
no um
i am
i remember just going home and kind of
not processing it and i had a friend
come over and
and then the next day i went straight
into glam i did the sound check
and i got on stage and i i posted that
post i was by myself i had no one
advising me my mom my sister wasn't
there to go
no
don't share this with the world like
make it real for you first
and i posted it
because i didn't have anyone there to
break on
i didn't have anyone to i don't flip and
cry again i didn't have anyone to
just fall apart on and just
that's what i needed that's what i
wanted you know
and so i did the show
the saddest point
of that whole experience for me other
than the
the painful part of it which i'm it's it
breaks my heart that so many women have
gone through it
even women i know
that i didn't know and i hated that i
didn't understand i couldn't support
them in the way they
needed me to because i didn't know it's
such a painful
physical painful emotional painful
experience that
you almost don't want to talk about it
because you need people to just to see
it to know but it's such a it's such a
it's such a trip you know and obviously
everyone's experience is different
because
you know the way the baby passes or it's
all different for everybody
and so i remember the hardest part for
me was
wasn't doing the show the show was
actually
kind of a weird trippy dream and i was
actually just really grateful that i
wasn't by myself
and that loads of people that i loved
turned up and came and you know were at
the show
it was when i got in the car
after the show
you know by myself
and i got home
and i opened my front door
and i closed the door and i fell to my
knees
and
that was the worst moment of the whole
experience was me realizing that
other than my career
being a mother and having a child has
been the biggest
excitement of my life like i've always
been super maternal i love children
like
it's just always been something i can't
even explain people go like you know
do you want to be a mom it's just
something that i think that you're
you gravitate towards or you kind of
learn to gravitate to gravitate towards
but
i felt like i had been given everything
i've ever wanted and then someone had
gone
but you can't have it but it was still
there you know i was still and i would
sing to it every night and you know and
so when i got home that night and i laid
there i've never felt so lonely in my
life
and
the empath in me was like
how so many people experience this like
it's just
and more than once
like
numerous times and i just remember
laying there
knowing that it was still there but it
wasn't there
you know and that went on for like
because you know it was a long time it
was over a week that i had to then go
and do it
a non-natural way
um
and it just
you know it was just the saddest
thing but at the same time
i knew that the reason it happened was
because i wasn't supposed to do it alone
and i stand by that now i knew as soon
as i found out that the baby had gone i
phoned my mum and i said i know
that i'm not supposed to do this by
myself
like i know that i'm supposed to find
someone that wants this as much as i do
and
it's such a honestly i it's a weird one
to talk about because it's such a
a head trip
because it's you're grieving not so much
even so much the the the baby or
whatever whatever
time you lose a baby you know i can't
even imagine like
women having stillborns and i just can't
even
fathom that and i
it you're grieving
the life that you imagined
like that you prepared in your mind as
well
um
it's almost a bit like you know when
you're really it's this really stupid
metaphor but when you're really excited
for a holiday
and then it gets cancelled and you kind
of go yeah it's okay i don't mind
but inside you're like i just bought all
these outfits and i got this and i've
got that it was like that times a
million
and
but i always will look for the silver
lining in every any moment of pain and
sadness
um
and
i'm grateful that i got to experience
being pregnant and i'm grateful that i
got to experience
that my body can do it not like not even
everyone can do it you know
and it's honestly brought me to some of
the happiest moments that i've felt um
because it's enabled it it's literally
given it's opened the door for me to
love myself deeper
so
i'm still processing the whole thing and
i still have moments of intense sadness
and grief but i also have moments of
excitement knowing that i won't do it
alone
the other thing that i when i sent you
that voice note
i think it was around the time when
you've done a big post about
dave
yeah
and that was so you're really bringing
out the big guns today yeah yeah he said
we're really going to talk about some
stuff well this is this is the
perspective i was looking from from the
outside in
what you had been going through in that
moment and you were being very open with
the journey yeah and within all of these
unimaginable instances you know
things that played out in your life it
was really as someone that's compelled
to understand humans in grief and their
emotions and psychology in the hope that
it might help me yeah you know
i was blown away by your gratitude even
in the wake of your miscarriage saying
things like i'm so happy i had
morning sickness yeah you got to
experience
the more it i got the happier i was
because i knew the baby was healthy
you'll never hear me complain if i'm
pregnant
and then the dave you did a post about
dave who was your security guard
and even that made me think about people
that i've been with me for you know for
a long time and been right by my side
through the storm yeah before the storm
and um
and that's that's more grief that's more
yeah more life lessons that we don't
want to have to learn right about yeah i
mean
it's interesting because
up until dave passed passing
i've lost people that i know of you know
but like
real close people
like he was one of the first
and
the hardest part about for me like
losing someone like that and i speak
broadly for anybody that's lost someone
is when you've had experiences that no
one else knows about
so when you lose somebody that
he woke me up every morning
and was the last person i'd see close my
hotel room door before i went to sleep
and would put on the do not disturb and
be like right seen the morning boss
for years and years and years and years
and years through me trashing a hotel
room in australia when i lost my mind to
me
fancying this guy that he told me not
today
or
having the best
success of a song or
selling out a show or not selling out a
show having to cancel the show or he was
the person that came to visit me the
first person that came to visit me when
i would just have my operation when i
was told i couldn't have kids like he
was my guy
like he was my big brother
like when there was turbulence he held
my hand for nine hours on the plane like
when you've
gone through
those experiences but you know you can
only grieve alone because no one else
has experienced
that those moments
with you
like that's
that was what was the hardest thing for
me is like
no one else was a part of really our
thing
because it was just me and him like he's
my security like he was just i would
make him get on the roller coaster he
was like no no just watch like come on i
would make and he was so big and he
would just sit next to me be like and
i'd be like i know you like it and like
there was a part of him that i know i
only got to see
you know it's an unusual experience to
be pushed together with someone that
closely for so long
and to experience theme parks and
traveling and airplanes and delays and
highs and lows and we would every after
every show
one of my things that i like to do which
i don't often do anymore
now because it you know it was a hell
thing
was go for a walk after the show whether
it was 2 a.m
it was raining
get me outside i need some air
i need to come back down to earth i need
my ringing in my ears to go i need to
like have a packet of crisps or a
sandwich i just need to like
and usually no one would be out because
it would be late so i could walk around
like i'd be in the rain soaking wet and
be like you've got to get you're going
to get sick and i'll be like germs make
you sick
ryan does amazing you know so like we
would have these conversations and
obviously i knew him and i knew
his own battle with his own sadness and
his own
when you tour for a living
when you're on tour you want to be at
home and when you're at home you want to
be on tour and there's this like push
and pull of like where do i belong like
i want to keep moving but i crave
stillness but when i'm at home it's too
still when i'm on
you know when you're on tour it's too
much moving and you crave stillness and
then when you're still it's like i need
to move
you know so i knew so much about him and
he knew so much about me
and i protected him as much as i could
as he protected me
um
so yeah i mean
like
one of the most important things for me
now
and has always been that because of my
dad too
is men need to talk
like
whenever i've got into a relationship
i'm so
adamant on my
partner having
their own life and their own group of
friends that they hang out with like
that they talk to and that they do the
things that they enjoy and like
i don't want
my life to become your life or to feel
like we have to be intertwined all the
time like
women have grown up with blogs and
magazines and books and this that and
the other and that's one of the things i
loved about you and this is why i said
yes to talking to you because
men don't talk enough about how they
feel
point blank you know and
almost are
raised to go
be respectful to women
you know or not it's not be respectful
to yourself
you know and
i watched people react to dave who was
this big six foot five
tattooed
bald guy
going oh you're gonna beat me up before
that even spoken to him
am i going him beat you up
like
he'd catch a fly in a cup and put it
outside you know
it's crazy because
the tears
um
between dave and jamal
and even the baby like
the things that those people
gave me in my life
are things that i know i have to find in
myself
like
my anxiety comes a lot from my fear of
being not being safe
and dave gave me that
and jamal always gave me self-belief
which is like my biggest anxieties are
self-belief and my fear
and so losing those two people in my
life
and then obviously the baby
was just such a huge part of
who i want to be in my life and what i
want to give to my children one day
um
i think that's why the grief is so
present right now because i'm in the
process of trying to give myself the
things that they
gave me
um
yeah the very special guys
and dave was
hard work
hard work
hilarious
did took no [ __ ]
and had my back 100
and i've not had anyone like that since
you know
in the photos you both look like jokers
oh my god he was the biggest joker the
biggest clown he would send me [ __ ]
while i was sitting in the voice chair
to try and make me laugh
and like
we just had all these jokes like we
would and we lived in this house in
australia together
and
it was whale season
so we would watch wales like we would
sit and have dinner and then we would
sit when we bought binoculars and we
would sit and watch like the sea and see
if we could find whales
and so it became this thing that every
time we'd be in the middle of a
conversation we were like wow and then
we'd all run to the window
so it became that thing for years that
like if there was an awkward moment or
one of us wanted to leave somewhere we
would say well um
that was like our code thing
yeah random and then he'd come up with
an excuse for him yeah yeah yeah yeah or
we'd just laugh because we'd be like if
someone said something stupid he'd be
like wow
like and it was just like he just got me
you know and it's very hard to find
people like that and i do believe that
you're right when you said about
expectation
i think that when you've experienced
i've had a handful of people in my
career
that have
loved me and seen me and heard me and
felt me and understood me and respected
me and elevated me
consistently
that are still here with me
or
aren't
anymore for whatever reasons whether
they've moved on or they've passed away
or
um
and i think it's hard that when you've
experienced that
to want anything
it's weird like i feel sometimes feel
safer
talking to dave this probably makes me
sound crazy at an event
and imagining him there
than i do with another security guard
and i know that may not make any sense
to anyone
but i just imagine him there
and i feel safe and i feel calm
um
so yeah he's definitely given me
a gift that i don't think he even ever
knew he did
i don't think he realized how special he
was to me
which i hate
i hate
and i wish i could have protected him
from himself like he protected me for
myself
that's the bit that hurts me the most
but
i know he would want me to live my life
as hard as i could
you know which is why i do try and make
decisions that i know only propel me to
a happier and more peaceful and secure
environment for myself and my future
family
and he's so clearly still with you
every day same with jamal
and the baby all of them
what do you like with letting people in
having been through a lot of
loss and these you know various
situations you've been through in your
life are you
do you let people in easily
because one would assume from some of
your characteristics the
openness the vulnerability that you had
people could just stride right in
it's probably something i'm working on
all the time
is that i do let people in i definitely
give people
more than they give me
most of the time
you know um
but i also think that's my nature like
i'm a hostess i'm a very like
a caregiver
like i'm
i like to cook and entertain and like
care for people and look after people
and
i think there's a there's a thin line of
people presuming that i have someone
else that's going to do that for me and
then also people that isn't just that's
not their love language
but also i'm very guarded and i think
that definitely in the last few years
have i i've got way more closed in
i wouldn't say that i have i have a fear
of like like i'm funny about people
letting people in
i think i let people in but maybe not to
the real real me there's only a few
people that really know
how much my brain is always working who
are those people
i have like five people
like childhood best friends
my parents are definitely people that
i've we've gone through our
you know as you do with your parents
um
you know we carry so much of our parents
good and bad
you know and i think that all of us know
that
my dad
i remember me and my dad when the tables
turned and i had to go to him do you
want to look at yourself
like i love you but
you know i carry some of your
traits that i don't like that i'm trying
to heal and i'm sitting with you and i
can see you doing them and it's irking
me and it and like triggering me and we
need to talk about it
you know and i'm grateful that i have
people that are
open to challenging me as much as i am
challenging them
um
but you know i don't have that many
people that i
trust wholeheartedly i don't
but i don't need that many and i'm
grateful i even have one because some
people don't even have one
and they're the people that i
cried for to because i think about how
lonely they must be
look at my life
i'm so lucky and so
grateful for everything i have
and i know that we've sat and spoken at
probably the most worst parts of my life
in the
most worst moments but
i also live a life of absolute
peace and happiness that i couldn't even
fathom
someone would tell me that this is what
my life was gonna look like
you know i'm beyond grateful
what about love then
love
love
so funny because i wrote a book when i
was
what was i when i wrote bloody
autobiography at 12. you know you got a
book deal and you're like okay and when
i look back at it now it's like there's
a whole section of like i like ice cream
and i'm just like who read this
um
and isn't she called nice to meet you
it's like my career so far in like 2012
and it'd be like six months in but i
remember
obviously with regards to like me
talking about relationships from the
beginning
and the impact that i had positively and
negatively to
myself my relationships my career
how i hurt people how people hurt me
i
wrote this big chapter on
love and personal love and then i
deleted it all and just put a little
thing of
i need to keep something personal
right and protected because if i talk
about everything so openly all the time
it's allowing
opinions and poison to seep in that
really do nothing for it
but can actually do something to it
and i think that
my last public relationship
um
which one was that
well it wasn't
even that i wanted to wanted it to be
public but the person was public no it
wasn't even that that was the one before
the last one okay it was that i was
frustrated that
you have to almost fame is weird because
even though people go people choose
personally not to post or not to speak
or not to be be seen
you can't live a normal relationship if
you
don't aren't seen so even if i don't
post a relationship
these people will hide and
hide in bushes and until they get a
picture and then
you don't want them to have the control
of what they say is
i know what you're talking about now you
know what i'm saying so this is where
you put
yes so obviously i was in a very very
public relationship
and
it was a very different experience for
me good bad ugly it was it was it was
actually very interesting because
i felt like i was experiencing what my
exes had felt like being
i was
i was them and he was me
right okay
he was on a whole another level of fame
and
and going through a very personal time
publicly and
i
was he was one of the biggest actors
that he is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and he's an incredible
father and was going for a really
personal
traumatic time and it was just a lot of
emotional
collisions you know of like both of our
lives at the same time and we got on
really well but again that same thing is
that when you're famous
you can go for dinner
on a date like how many dates have you
been on where you would never see them
again
right
but you get photographed and you're both
famous and they put it on the internet
and go
exclusive and you're like
and that wasn't what happened but you
know we got seen and it kind of
propelled
into something probably
more than maybe it was also because of
what was going on in his own life and
then there was this comparison and it
was just
it was so many things that
i always say that there's a lot of
things that fame
control
that you can't control and there's a lot
of things in this life that we asked for
and then there's some things that we
don't but happen anyway
and so
that whole experience definitely made me
go i just need more privacy and i need
to have something that
isn't
always me talking about it and like
being open because
even if people really understand it
everyone just everybody slows down at
the car crash
very rarely do people get out and help
and now people don't just slow down now
people slow down and they film they zoom
in they comment
they
send to somebody else
they will pretend something else
happened that was there that wasn't like
that's what it is now right
so then when i met
someone in the pandemic
and who wasn't famous and i was very
protective of that
when then when we did get seen i was
like i don't want to talk about it like
and we were together for like dating for
maybe a month and then obviously it was
put out everywhere
on this one picture and i was like
you know my my
frustration of like
the way they worded
all of it and i just was like no this
isn't what it is like if you wanna
i don't i hate that the press can
control the narrative
i hate that
but i also get get it but it doesn't
mean that you sometimes don't just go
you know like
and you did a post basically saying i
want to control the narrative yeah
exactly and it wasn't me going like
we're going to get married we're going
to do this it was just like this is what
it is this is who it is
like just and then they did piss off to
some degree you know it was like okay
and then all the like the picture they
posted at me and i laughed about it i
looked like an old man that owned a boat
that was wearing a wig like it was so
bad and i was just like really guys this
is the picture you're gonna use with
both of us and like it was just terrible
but
there's that thin line of like
[ __ ] everybody i'm gonna live the life i
wanna live and i'm going to experience
love
like my mum says to me fallen in love as
many times as you can
it will stick or it won't how many times
have you been properly in love
once
because i can actually see
my life with that person and i've never
had that before
sounds recent
maybe it is maybe it isn't maybe it
isn't
who knows who knows um we might never
know and i may like and i may never know
yeah like i just feel like love is a
constant moving experience and i think
that when you meet new people you always
want to dumb down what you've
experienced because you don't want to
make them feel bad but the truth is all
we're ever doing is going is this love
do you want to be with me are we going
to get married like do can we live
together like would you take a bullet
for me do i really want to meet your
parents yeah it's a constant it's a lot
yeah it's a lot and i think that
i've been in relationships where
in the process of me working out if it's
what i want or not what i want
the press are
giving the narrative that it's exactly
what i want and it is going to happen
and it's this and it's that and i'm like
we may never have been official
or we were or we may have been engaged
or we may have like
just been mates the amount of times i've
been in relationships with my friends
that i've just gone to dinner with you
know i've like the amount of times that
people have set up look like i've been
pregnant
little do they know obviously now it
doesn't happen
and i think if the press did say that
now i think that i would probably feel
confident to say something because i see
them do it to so many women
without knowing what they're internally
going through
i
constantly write the line between
not giving a [ __ ] and wanting to protect
it to every
little part of me
because
i would be lying if i didn't say that
what other people
think or say or constantly
believe
doesn't
bother me
when you walked in you said i asked you
what's front of mind and you said i'm
thinking about like the next chapter
yeah of jessie j and my life
what is that next chapter as we look
forward
acting on my instincts
making music that i love
making music that
feels like it speaks to myself
as much as it speaks to other people
finding a team of people that have the
same passion as me
and
giving my personal life as much
nurturing as my career
and acting
yeah i'm acting right now
um
i really want to do stand up i mean me
sitting at crime for the last three
hours isn't giving that people that
impression but
knock knock um
i
yeah i definitely want to do acting
at some point
like the west end stuff i mean i yeah i
mean right now i'm in the process of
like
trying to create a one-woman show right
um
which is what jamar was helping me with
um which is a combination of
the things that i love the most which is
therapy and talking
and honesty and emotions and standing in
the middle of them and feeling the storm
and the joy and the sunshine and the
rain and all of it
singing
and singing when i mean singing singing
as hard as i can as loud and high and as
soft and as low and everything as i can
and making people laugh
you know and combining those three
things and
don't know what it looks like have an
idea but you know life does this
yeah
um
and
preparing my body to
try again to
be a parent
you know at some point in the next few
in the next few years for sure
thank you thank you are you gonna write
notes about me in your book now
no actually this is part of a tradition
we have here where the the last guest
who you'll never know who they are
writes a question for the next guest and
then that just keeps going so i love
that it's like all the guests are
actually speaking to each other but they
just don't know who they're talking to
so what are you clear about now that one
year ago you didn't know
all my dreams personally and
professionally
are
able to happen
with people by my side
and i don't have to do everything by
myself
i think that's the biggest thing for me
is i'm
a very independent
i've got i can do it i i don't need help
i don't need support
person
that's [ __ ] like i need i need
people around me that
want to do what i want to do and i enjoy
being a team player
and i don't think that was clear to me a
year ago
well jesse thank you thank you for
the conversation you know as i said you
before we started recording there was a
reason why i wanted to speak to you and
it's for all the reasons that you know
i've discovered today you've been
through so much but on the other side of
that is
tremendous wisdom and willingness to
share it with people who
you've seen from even the way you've
shared your story and the impact you've
had when you do those acoustic sets yeah
what happens to the audience when you
start talking about that yeah you see
the resonance right i'm grateful to
as i said the biggest thing for me is
never to think that i've had it any
worse than anyone else because i talk
about it it's knowing that
i'm
giving someone space that may not be
able to find that for themselves
to
grieve or to feel something that they
need to feel
yeah
and the other tremendous part of my
admiration too comes from this this
watching you realize that the only way
to live is if you're
emotionally in alignment with what
you're doing and it's making you feel
good and that really is the guiding
force of our lives as opposed to english
people say you know trust your gut yeah
literally it's your second brain
trust your gut
you know like and don't just trust your
instincts act on them like if something
doesn't feel right it's because it's not
and then the other part the third part
is your talent which is
hey yeah
do you like that
i was thinking more the whitney thing
out in china
whitney isn't she the best but but you
are just like i know that i'm blowing
smoke up your ass but you are
different
like when i listen to him say i don't so
i'll be honest with you i don't listen
to loads of um
music in your when i would say in your
genre but you're not really in one genre
but you know what you mean but you and
um maybe one other artist
can get me like and that's i think a
credit to your talent and also
what what's behind the music you can
feel it with certain people and when i
was doing the research for this episode
i got like i'm like because i'd get two
hours into listening to one of you
listening to the rose album or something
else like [ __ ] i need to read and then
i'd play another song and get sucked
back into it emotionally and it was
taking me to places and for me that's
what like really good artists do they
take me to places and take me to that
place and liberate me from whatever
was there and that's what you do and so
thank you wherever you're at in your
life yeah you've got that thank you you
know no one can ever take that you've
got it yeah and few have so thank you
for that gift and thank you for sharing
all of it thank you
appreciate that so much
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast we are all
looking for ways to live a little bit
more sustainably and to make more
conscious choices in our day-to-day
routines so when a brand like my energy
who i've spoken about before offered to
sponsor this podcast i felt like and i
knew deep down inside that i had to help
them share their mission to create an
even greener world it feels like there's
not much more fulfilling than that and
their products provide an easy and cost
effective way to make a sustainable
switch in your life and they've got some
existing new products coming out that i
can't wait to use myself and i'll let
you know as i use those products how i
get on so if you're a my energy customer
at the moment let me know your favorite
products down below in the comments
section and if you haven't checked them
out yet go to myenergy.com and find out
a lot more about who they are and what
they're doing if you're one of those
people that wants to make a sustainable
switch
myenergy.com is the place for you
[Music]
[Music]